die migrationskrise ist zurück wir
dachten wir hätten sie bewältigt aber
wir haben sie befürchte ich nur
verdrängt und im Stundentakt gehen nun
Hilfe rufe ein aus den Ländern aus den
Kommunen Hilferufe aus Thüringen zum
Beispiel aus Hamburg ein ganz
dramatischer hilfe-appell kann man aus
Sachsen wo der neue Innenminister
Schuster mit Namen von der CDU gesagt
hat wir halten das nicht mehr aus 80%
der erstaufnahmeplätze sind bereits
belegt es gibt Menschen die aus Polen
und Tschechien kommen aus sicheren
Drittstaaten um in Deutschland Asyl zu
beantragen das im schönen
Baden-Württemberg dort hat sich der
Landrat von Tübingen zu Wort gemeldet
der gleichzeitig auch dem Landes
Kreistag vorsteht und er hat gesagt ich
zitiere ihn wir locken die Flüchtlinge
in die sein Wort Zitat soziale
Hängematte das heißt die migrationskrise
kommt der
migrationsturbonames Bürgergeld wird neu
angeworfen das ist leider schlecht für
alle Beteiligten insofern ist es leider
momentan ein Trauerspiel